facebook instagram twitter les réseaux
sociaux font désormais partie intégrante
de notre vie c'est ainsi que j'allais
c'est une habitude donc c'est hyper
addictif contrôler tout le temps et en
fait on se rend pas compte du temps qui
passe si en moyenne dans le monde nous
passons 2h27 sur ces plateformes les
durées d'utilisation sont pourtant très
variable selon les pays et tranches
d'âge et les catégories sociales si on
numéro en retrouve le nigeria est des
philippines avec plus de quatre heures
de connexions par jour les français sont
7e et passerait quant à eux d'une heure
quarante six par jour sur les réseaux la
tranche d'âge la plus active étant les
15-24 ans qui représentent 12 % des
connexions cinquante et une minutes
seulement pour les japonais sans doute
plus connecté à la réalité mais surtout
parce que la population les plus âgés
alors les français passent une heure
quarante six par jour sur les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que c'est trop
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas du tout on est pas du tout
dans les pays qui passent le plus de
temps devant
le moins de temps c'est le japon 51e
minute faut dire que bon il travaille
beaucoup l'allemagne c'est 1h29 la
suisse 1h33 la france 1h46 les anglais
une en 48 et après ça monte les chinois
1h57 maintenant faut qu'ils se cachent
après sur les réseaux le maroc pas mal
jackal entre et lorraine le pays où le
plus sont les réseaux c'est le nigeria
est ce que vous avez son poids il sembla
que soit le point de départ de
nombreuses plateformes un petit peu en
doublant effectivement toutes les
magouilles et les combines on reproche
aux réseaux partirait de l'effet fiscal
sont assez voilà c'est assez libérale
c'est plus facile de se mettre là bas
qu'ailleurs
la nana qui se tire une balle
en fait les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
c'est tellement présent dans tout dans
tous qu en fait on est obligé d'y aller
dire que c'est le travail là comme le
les médias la détente ce jeu l'amour le
sexe vous voulez aujourd'hui vous le
retrouvez sur les réseaux sociaux
chacun son truc à tranas qu'ils sont
plus forts d'autres choses que d'autres
croient alors gardez une moussaka où est
ce que je me dis je suis
ceci le téléphone de magali on était
regardée dans les paramètres et sur la
semaine tu as course e mails et réseaux
sociaux 13h20
deux heures par jour c'est dans la
moyenne vous pensez qu'on reste
évidemment que c'est beaucoup trop alors
lui a joué le dire il passe sa vie
entière sur les réseaux jamais peur tout
le temps du tout j'ai dîné avec lui
alors je vous le dis j'ai dansé remonter
les noms j'ai dîné avec lui sur mon
téléphone tourmalet c'est pas pour aller
voir les articles sur voilà sur la d
exposition d'eric hollande alors
trop parce que bien souvent les réseaux
sociaux c'est le vide intersidéral en
revanche ce qui est choquant dans ce
sondage c'est que ce sont les réseaux
sociaux qu'on croit un peu dépassée
comme facebook qui arrive largement
facebook est beaucoup plus utilisé que
tik tok snapshot pourquoi parce que les
personnes plus âgées sont plus
nombreuses et utilise encore facebook et
c'est là qu'on voit personne en europe
n'a pu battre instagram et c'est ça
reste entre guillemets des niches
réservées aux personnes un peu plus
jeunes voilà vous allez sur ce thème
chat
sait pas si
ces affiches et rien de plus alors c'est
pas grave c'est tout voilà bah oui voilà
c'est que sur ce match c'était un filtre
qui fait fureur c'est le filtre de fiona
et de et de shrek ah bon oui alors j'ai
pour l'heure alors ressembler bahavar
êtes vous vous mettez votre tête et vous
êtes vous d ressembler à fiona ah ouais
ouais je
sais c'est possible d'empêcher non mais
franchement ça débute il faut une lance
à incendie pour n'est pas grave c'est
pas possible
photo de de la barre
oui nous dit vous savez moi ce qui
m'attriste en fait c'est le sondage qui
a été réalisé le mois dernier et qui
prouve combien notre génération et
combien la période et presque dramatique
à ce niveau là c'est que les réseaux
sociaux sont le loisir préféré des
français même nous alessio lanzi
vous rappelle qu' on est dans un pays
qui connaît des moments très compliqués
que le réseau social pour eux c'est un
c'est gratuit parfois c'est assez
divertissant mais franchement quand je
défile quand je dis que ça fait du tout
rires y a pas que des saloperies quoique
on arrive à l'instant on a frisé la
belle hausse à l'ange radio ckoi et
sportif qui coûte pas bien cher c'est
vrai ce que je veux faire préférer c'est
dur quand même si on aurait fait quoi
pendant le confinement sans les réseaux
sociaux font de tels mandats konaré
c'est à s'y mettre on était à fond et on
était bien content et ses primes hadrami
c'était notre âme ans c'était notre
groupe de copains et pourquoi tout rires
oui mais alors pourquoi j parce que moi
j'utilise ce à cinq heures par jour tu
me rends bien compte que c'est beaucoup
trop mais j'en suis dépendante et c'est
plein de fois j'ai pas envie de sortir j
aurais je préfère rester et en fait
c'est ça ce qu'on dit dans l'air et on
préfère rester sur instagram c'est
devenu d'inscrire ces boîtes parfois
fronton ses traders alors monsieur
deckers sks que la reine et sur les
réseaux absolument à rennes et sur les
réseaux sociaux mobiles absolument qu'il
tweet mais on a remarqué
cocoon et nous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme des kings avaient très très
performante a même envoyé un message sur
la lune la reine elizabeth ii père
durant tout ce qu'il voulait dire
c'était que là vous avez remarqué la
belgique n'est absolument pas dans ce
classement un peu moins friands des
réseaux sociaux deviennent des français
est ce que je voulais dire aussi c'est
qu'on ne prenne pas tellement delà de
l'âge dans le fond mais moi je vous
assure et c'est sans doute dû à ma
spécificité journalistique mais j'ai
beaucoup de personnes du troisième âge
qui m'a en livre sur les rayonnages un
peu avancé et qui sont vraiment fidèle
sur un public qui est fidèle et c'est un
public aussi on a l'impression qu'ils
cherchent à combler un peu la solitude
ça et voilà donc il n'y a pas que les
jamais entendu tu faisais que terme la
nouvelle génération il ya aussi parce
que pendant finement les avait donnés la
fondation des hôpitaux de france
beaucoup d' ipad aux maisons de
retraites justement pour qu'il garde
cette communication qu'ils appellent
antisociaux et moi ma grand mère me
regarder sur snapshot par exemple la
journée sur ce projet ça va ce n'est pas
que des mauvaises choses les derniers
jours